office workers will look back at 2020 as
something of a tipping point in the
world of work
largely workers prove to their employers
that they could get their jobs done from
home
so what does the future hold for the
office
80 of people who work from home during
the lockdown
say they'd like to continue working at
least one day from home
in the future meanwhile two out of three
of us
say that we're longing to return to the
office in some form
in other words we want to have our cake
and eat it we want the best parts of the
office
and the best parts of working from home
the workplace property expert anthony
slumpers
said no firm ever wanted an office they
wanted productive employees
and the office was just one way to
create that over the last few years
many companies had moved to open plan
offices well the promise was that we
would be let loose in vast
workplace savannas free to meet and
bounce ideas off each other
in fact open plan offices tended to make
us feel like we were constantly
interrupted
and unable to get anything done we've
realized offices are good for some
things
the office had something called a
network effect those chance encounters
bumping into colleagues and sharing
thoughts just casually that we're
finding so difficult to replace
and there seems to be some pretty good
evidence that our best a-ha moments
happen in these chance encounters
professor sandy petland
from the massachusetts institute of
technology says the reason why these
conversations are so effective
is that these are the moments that we
don't find ourselves supervised by our
bosses we feel free to have honest
discussions
so if the office was good for a few
things and the top one
chatting to colleagues is the one we're
struggling to replace
what's the answer maybe your firm will
join something that's starting to be
called
the tw and t revolution where workers
work from the office
on tuesdays wednesdays and thursdays but
from home
on mondays and fridays and no doubt in
time
someone will come up with a catchy name
for people who work like this
other firms are being still more
adventurous saying they want to free up
workers
to do their work whenever they feel most
productive they're adopting
what's being known as asynchronous
working when we do something
synchronously
it means we're coordinated in time like
the swimmers at the olympics
asynchronous work says how about we
allow people to give their feedback
or their ideas whenever they're feeling
most inspired
companies who do this say allows workers
the flexibility
to take their kids to school or even do
leisure activities and this is what the
asynchronous working firms
believe will attract the best workers to
come to work for them
expect to hear a lot more of the word
hybrid
at the more adventurous end of hybrid
some firms are even talking about
only getting their employees together
one week a quarter
meaning that almost certainly they don't
need an office more than anything
one thing seems increasingly certain for
many office workers the era of getting
up
every day and going to the same place
seems to be a thing of the past
and the question is will you miss it